If you come from an Islamic perspective,
you don't have an answer on what the
injeil is. You don't know who wrote it.
You don't know when it was written. You
don't know nothing about it. You don't
even know what was in it. You don't
know.
Yeah, you're right. I don't know what it
is.
So,
but it in the end, if you got to look at
from
when in doubt, this is what the Quran
says. When in doubt, come to us. Go to
the people of the book. That's what you
should do. When you want to know what
the angel is, come to the people who
have it. Don't say we don't have it when
you don't know what it is. That's silly.
Interesting. No, I I definitely I
definitely didn't how would I say I
didn't think that the NGO was referring
to the New Testament. I I I do like your
content, man. You know, you're very
respectful and I like how you you do
give really criticized in depth
questions, which made me even question.
So, if you can I start with the question
that you have right now. What is the
NGO?
Yes.
Awesome, man. I one more thing. What's
your name? I know it's got Can I get
your actual name if you don't mind?
Avery.
Avery. Very nice to meet you Avery. I'm
Ka.
So the Injil was a revelation that was
given to Isaam. And basically what this
revelation was was a book with
information. Now a lot of people get
this misconception that the NGO is the
Bible. It is not. The reason I believe
and form the evidence of it not being
the Bible is because the NGO was given
to Jesus. That is said strictly in the
Quran. The angio was given to Jesus. Do
you agree with that? The angel was given
to Jesus. The New Testament came after
Jesus. Would you agree with that? Okay.
So, there's a distinction right there
that the Injio was a message, a book
that was given to Jesus. Now, the
question is, what proof do we have that
Jesus really even had this? And he was
even given this message.
Let's grant it. Let's grant that he
actually had this NGL. This gospel was
granted.
Yeah. Okay. So, so what's what do you
think the NGO is? Does my Does that my
definition of the NGO? Is it similar to
you? Would you say
I'm going to I'm going to show you that
your idea of the NGO is actually closer
to mine than you think.
Okay.
Okay. So, we understand that Jesus was
given the NGO. Was he getting Was he g
was it given to him like orally or was
did he did Jesus actually have a
physical written book?
So, it is not it is not addressed in the
Quran. So, I cannot tell you. I'm not
going to give you an answer that I'm
going to say yes, it was written. It
doesn't it says we were given it. Now,
it could have been oral, could have been
written. I I just personally I'm not a
scholar. I I don't know.
So it says the same thing like about the
Quran with Muhammad. It says that we
sent down the book to you or prophet,
right?
Okay. So you're right. You're right.
You're right. You're right. It was a
book. You're right.
Yeah. So it's a it's a book and even the
Quran is called a book but not
necessarily a physical book that
Muhammad actually had in his hands. A
revelation that he would recite orally
of course.
So could we say that the same thing
could be similar about the angel? When
it says the angel was given to Jesus,
it's a it's a revelation that
it depends. It depends. I have a
question for you. What do you think the
Torah was? Do you think the Torah was
also in that oral transmission or do you
think it was handwritten also?
Well, we're getting to the handwritten
part. I believe that these books were
eventually handwritten. I'm just I'm
talking about their initial revelation.
Okay. So, the Okay. So, this is my
problem with your your idea of the
Injil. I think you're trying to say that
the Quran is referring to the as the New
Testament. And the problem with that is
is correct me if I'm wrong. I'm not
100%. I'm not a scholar of this stuff,
but the New Testament was written quote
it's it's not it's not confirmed.
There's some evidence to it, but to some
of his eyewitnesses. Correct.
Yeah. The New Testament was written by
his disciples.
Okay. Which is the claim. I mean, me
personally, that's a whole another
topic. That's a whole another topic. I'm
going to show you that you believe the
same thing about the NGO.
So, what is your question again? Or you
want me to keep going?
Yeah, I'm I'm going to show you that you
believe the same thing about the NGO. Or
at least you should.
So, like, so that that's why I'm asking
when it comes to the NGO, as you say,
like the Quran doesn't say specifically,
but let's reason about it. The Quran
says that they that the that the Quran
says that the Quran was sent down to
Muhammad as a book, but we know that
Do you know where it says as a book? Cuz
me
Well, yeah. Like, so for for example, if
you go to chapter 3:3.
Okay, I'll pull it up right now. I got
it right here. Can you give me a second?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay, cool. I got it right here. And you
said three. Three.
Yeah. Let me double check to see. Make
sure it says book.
Hope I've been the nicest person today.
I don't know. Bro, you skipped me like
three times, too.
You I I thought I saw you just come up.
No, no, you're good. You're good. All
right. So, it says So, it says he has
revealed to you gradually this perfect
book. Okay. No, you're right. So he has
revealed this perfect book which meets
all your requirements fulfilling the
prophecies and scriptures. Okay.
Right.
Right. So now we know that Muhammad
wasn't sent down an actual you know
Yes.
something physical with pages.
Of course.
So this is just a revelation that he
would recite orally but it's called a
book and and sent down to Muhammad.
Yeah. Cuz they later formed it into a
book.
Exactly. So
So would you would say that's the same
with the New Testament?
I would say that's that's the same with
the NGO.
Okay. So here's my thing with that. The
problem with that is because when the
disciples wrote down the Bible, they
wrote it in their own well what Jesus
says, they wrote it in their own
narratives. Correct. Meaning
they wrote they wrote the gospel
according to according to what they
experienced.
Yes. What they were inspired by.
Correct.
Yep.
Okay. That is a little bit different how
the Quran was cuz the Quran is everyone
is writing down the same meth.
No, it's not. No. People were writing
down different different uh ways of
recitate reciting. So they were writing
according to what they heard.
I was getting a phone.
Oh, yeah. Sorry.
Wait, wait, wait. So, start over again.
I'm so sorry. I was getting a phone
call.
No. Yeah, I was saying that. But that
that's not true. That people were also
writing down and memorizing the Quran
differently.
You were saying they were writing it
down differently.
Yep.
Maybe different recentations, the
dialects. Is that what you're referring
to?
Not dialects. It's different. Like, it's
not a dialectic problem. It's re It's
differences. Like we still have those
today. Like there's different Qurans
today.
Are you talking about like whoosh wash
like
wash hops all?
Yeah, but that that's dialects, is that
not?
No, it's not. It's words. It's like
dialect is how you annunciate or
pronounce a word.
But isn't it isn't it the like I said,
I'm not I'm not a scholar on this.
I'm not like I I really don't want to
like like a lot of people who come on
here, they're really disrespectful. I
hope I'm not doing that.
You're cool so far.
Yeah. Correct me if I'm wrong, but I'm
pretty sure whoosh, hush, all that.
That's different dialects. That's not
different. Are you Are you sure?
Yes.
So, I I I I've seen where that comes
from, where it was revealed in seven
different modes. You know that, right?
Yeah. But your scholars don't know what
that means.
I mean, that's that's cool.
Look, listen. The different modes and
the different recitations are two
different things. So, you have different
modes or off roof.
Yes.
Which they they translate as letters. So
you got the seven letters but then you
also have the the seven different
recitations or dialects seven different
dialects. The modes and the dialects are
two different things.
Okay.
So what I'm what I'm presenting to you
is that you have Qurans that are that
have different words you know
but they don't contradict each other in
meaning do they?
Yes
they do contradict each other in
meaning.
Yes some of them. Not not all of them
but some of them.
Is it is it your belief meanings? It
depends on your theology. But yes, like
so for example, there's there's one
when you get into that type of stuff,
I'm not I really don't want to be rude,
y'all. I'm not
I mean I don't want to go I'm ignorant
of that type of stuff when it comes to
rules and stuff. So, you know, you you
can you can you can do your best and
trying to educate me and stuff 100%.
I I'd like to show you this one day. You
know, we we'll have good convers. I'll
show you.
From what I've seen from the scholars
that I've read on it, they've said that
it doesn't contradict each other. Oh,
they're lying. Like I I literally have I
literally have live streams where we go
through the textual variants, the ones
that contradict in meaning. We go
through them. Even even even some even
the early scholars of Islam, like if you
look up what look up Alab for example,
he'll admit that that people early
Muslims would argue over certain texts
and certain readings because one
contradicted another. They admitted that
it was contradictory. So
Oh yeah. I mean, maybe I'm not 100% on
that, bro. I got to read the hadith for
myself. I'm actually starting to read
Bardi and stuff. So, maybe maybe that's
something I learned later down.
Obviously, like I said, when it comes to
that type of stuff, like I'm not going
to I'm not going to you and
give you lies. I'm just saying from what
I've heard from my scholars and they
give it more in-depth reasoning, which
personally, like I said, I'm not a
scholar in this where I can tell you
that. But you were asking about the
Ineal.
Yeah. So basically the idea that the
inje is something that was revealed to
Jesus that Jesus had.
Yes.
But it was he orally recited it. He
orally preached it. It wasn't something
I don't I don't know. I don't know if he
orally preached it though cuz I I see
what you're trying to say. You're trying
to make the comparison of the Quran to
the like it's the same. It was orally
preserved and then it was written down
by his companions. Correct?
Yep.
Okay. Now with that, here's my problem
with that. when you got to understand
from a Sunni perspect cuz I am Sunni
from a Sunni perspective we said all the
companions agreed on the you know what
to write down it wasn't like they were
writing it down in their own narratives
such as the Gospel of Mark, Luke, John
and etc. You know what I mean? It's not
like they were how would I say if I put
this word you're going to put that word
too if I put this word and I know you
said okay well this is where we had that
problem with the different dialects and
stuff and jewels and stuff. Like I said,
me personally, I don't know how like
that much of a difference it makes from
my scholars.
Literally, when you have what is called
a huff recitation or recitation,
yes,
you're literally getting a recitation of
the Quran according to these people.
Yes. No, I know that. I know the the
imams. Yes. The the different the seven.
I I agree. I agree.
Yeah.
But that doesn't that I I don't think it
changes the meaning. Well, I it does,
but let's let's let's just let's just go
let's go with how it let's say it
doesn't change the meaning.
Okay,
just let me just grant you that for the
sake of the discussion because for our
discussion it doesn't matter cuz we're
not we're not talking about that. The
fact that you have even a similar belief
with the Quran that you're getting the
Quran, a recitation of the Quran from a
particular person.
Yeah. according to what they heard and
what they memorized. Yep. While others
are getting the Quran based off another
person that what based on what they
heard and memorized and so on and so
forth. You have the Quran according to
Hos, the Quran according to Wars, the
Quran according to Dury, the Quran
according to Kir, the Quran according to
Khalif.
Yeah. Yeah. I get that. I get that.
So we we have we have the Gospel
according to the Gospel according to
Luke. Stuff like that.
No. Oh, okay. I see. I see. I see. Ah,
okay. I see. That that makes a little
bit more sense. Thank you for I see how
you did that. Now my personal thing is
but when hops and wash how would I say
they start the beginning the same right?
They still would start with Alfatia and
end in Elnas would.
Yeah. But there's even a difference in
but that is a good point to bring into
though because I don't want to be rude
or like you know try to say ah I got you
but like if they're all still agreeing
the order of the Quran and how it was
transmitted that's not the same as the
Gospel of Luke, Matthew, Mark.
Well, they don't though. They don't
they're not exactly the same. They're
not even Even when you like So if you
compare if you compare Huffs and Worsh
even the verse numbering is different.
So like in Huff's verse like chapter 2
verse 86 would be chapter 2 verse 87 in
the wash even the so the ordering of the
verses is is even a little different now
how what happened there I don't exactly
know the detail on I have to go back and
research I forgot but I don't think it's
a big deal but you know it's it's not
identical. Yeah. I mean, like I said,
that's something that I have to do more
research on where I'm not 100% on like
I'm not going to give you information
where I definitely I definitely see how
that that goes though and I see how
you're trying to compare hops and wash
to according to Matthew, according to
John, according to that and that the NGO
was just revealed through four different
perspectives. Is that what you were
trying to say?
Correct.
Okay. that that could make sense and
that's something that could but me
personally this is where I would have a
little bit of a problem with correct me
if I'm wrong but you know there's still
verses that were added into the Bible
like in the New Testament. So oh can I
can I keep going? So I'm not 100% on
this so correct me if I'm wrong but the
the idea of the story of the adulterous
woman I'm not I'm pretty sure I heard a
Christian scholar saying that that was
later added. So let's let's go with this
idea that that there was a plugin within
the New Testament. How how would these
scholars know that?
How would they know that? That's a good
question. Well, you would have to see
what comes first from manuscripts.
Correct.
Beautiful. So for them for them to say
something was added means they have
access to the earlier ones to be able to
tell if something is added. Right.
Yep. Yep. Yep.
Proving that what they have is still
preserved because they can tell if
something is fabricated or not.
Yeah. So,
so from what do you believe in the idea
of Q and
those are those are all theoretical they
don't exist.
Okay. So you don't believe in that. So
you wouldn't listen to Bartman and what
he says?
No. Not not
no we listen to Bart from what I said
from what I've read
like Bartman says that that Jesus was
crucified under Pontius Pilate and
that's the most certain thing. No, no,
of course. Of course. But he has to do
that on a historical point because
everyone who's ever come into this earth
needs an birth and a death. You know
what I mean?
No, not really. But, but again,
one, respectfully, you can't show me one
historical person.
No, that's that's not the point.
Do you see Do you know where he's
getting the historical information from?
He's getting it from the Bible.
Exactly. So, he counts he counts the New
Testament as historically reliable on
the Bible.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. But he he does say
he does say that Jesus didn't claim to
be God and that was something later
Emillet did. That is something he
believes.
You can debate later on.
He actually switches he actually
switches on that too. He he switches his
position on that as well. The one thing
that you got to
posted last week and um I think he's
still pretty firm on it.
But he's not a he's not a theologian.
No, he's a New Testament scholar though.
Yeah. He he even says he even says that
no, he's a textual scholar. a textual
critic. He's not he's not a an author.
Yeah. And a the a theologian. He can't
interpret scripture.
So what he said was
he literally says he literally says that
nowhere in Mark does it point to the
divinity of Christ.
Yes. He says and then now ask the
gospels and it's not really until
but then in his debate and somebody came
and questioned him and asked him about a
verse in Mark walking on water
and then no but claiming to be the son
of man who will be sit at the right hand
of the father. Yep.
And is this a divine claim? And he said,
and Bartman says, "Yes, he literally
reigged on everything he said about Mark
not teaching the deity of Christ." But
he he's he's not a theologian, bro. He's
not good at it.
No, no, no. I'm I'm sure. I'm sure.
But going going back to the main issue,
though, is
what this is and how I'm showing you
that it make it makes more sense.
You believe as a textual critic from
Let me finish.
Oh no. Yeah. My fault. My fault. I
didn't even hear you. My fault.
So talking about the NGO.
Yeah. the importance of this. Going back
to the subject that the NGO, what you
believe about the NGO or what you need
to believe about the Injil would match
what our New Testament is a revelation
that Jesus preached.
Yes.
That was then later on written down by
his disciples.
Okay. Yes. So this is where the problem
would come in with the whole idea if we
can even prove if the Bible came from
the disciples. Now that's something
that's debated upon. Every Muslim in the
world believes that Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John were eyewitnesses. But what we
disapprove on is that Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John were the gospel writers
of the authors of Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John.
Doesn't matter.
Huh?
It doesn't matter because
it would matter cuz you have to know who
you got to know who you get your
information from. That's all.
Okay. So, I I would ask you, who wrote
the inje?
Who wrote the? That's a very good
question. Well, the would come from his
disciples. Did we not say that?
Okay. So, so if if we're talking about
the NGO, notice how you now we both
agree like what you believe about the
NGO is what I believe about the New
Testament.
Great point. Yes. Well,
that's that's what the point was to
bring this to.
So, so this is disagree though. I don't
think the New Test I don't think the
authors of the New Testament are the
same authors of the Injeal.
Why?
That's a good point. And the reason is
is from textual critics like Bertrman.
And I know you said you he's not a
theologian scholar, but
what about what about Gary Habbermask?
Oh, yeah. Can I can I get can I finish
Mike Lakona? What about
No, I got you. Of course. Of course. So,
correct me if I'm wrong, but Bartman
says that there is huge amount of
copying between Mark and and uh Luke or
Matthew.
How do you know that didn't go on with
the NGO? Let's say that I man's
position. How do you know that that's
not what took place with the NGO?
What do you mean? I was like, can you
give me a little
I'm just I'm just repeating what you
said. Now you're you're appealing to
Burman. Yeah.
Who says that there was copying among
the the authors of the New Testament.
How do you know that there wasn't
copying among the authors of the Injil?
We don't know.
So then this still doesn't prove
we don't have we don't have the angil
anymore and you're claiming we have the
But wait, you're you're claiming that I
don't have the angil anymore yet.
Everything that you believe about the
angil is describing the new what the New
Testament is. So I believe in the New
Testament to we could say that the New
Testament came from the NGO, but it
isn't the NGO. So exactly. So So let me
give you an an example.
Yeah, break that down.
Yeah, I got you. So maybe maybe what how
I'm seeing the New Testament is that the
New Testament came from whatchamacallit
the angel but they started to write it
in their own divinely inspired ways
instead of keeping it in the original
way that Jesus recited it and repeated
it. So would you say that the Old
Testament is the infallible word of God
just like the Quran? Cuz I know you
don't believe the New Testament is the
infallible word of God. I know you
believe it to be the inspired words of
God.
You know I do. I I I don't believe that
there's any any flaws in in any of the
scripture as long as it goes for its
theology and its consistency. Now, as
far as like textual variance, that's
that's one thing, but those don't bring
falsehood or flaws to the actual text.
No, I agree with that.
But how how does that answer the
question?
No. Yeah, I got you right now. I got you
right now.
So, you're saying that the New Testament
is something that came from the NGO. How
do you
Well, let me finish this. The new the
nil is the infallible words of God.
Correct. Would we agree with Yes. You
would agree with that, too?
Sure.
Okay.
It's the New Testament. So, yeah.
So, you believe the New Testament is
also an infallible word of God.
Yeah.
Oh, okay. I correct me if I'm wrong. I I
think I saw in a video where you said we
don't believe it's the infallible word
of God, but we believe it's the
inspired.
No, I I No, I desri No, I described what
infallible was in the video that you're
talking about with Rouslon. I said that
what we believe about the Bible is that
it's not the exact about it's not the
exact word for word word of God.
Oh, okay. You know that's that's what I
believe the angel to be then.
All right. Where does where does the
Quran describe it to be that?
Well, if it came from God, wouldn't it?
I also believe that the New Testament
came from God.
Okay, great point. But we believe that
the Injeal is the word that like
infallible words of
No, I understand infallible. I also
believe the New Testament
infallible. What's what's the word that
to describe
word for word?
Word for word.
You believe it's the word for word. You
believe it's the exact words of God.
The angel
verbatim.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. That's what
Yeah. Where does the Quran say that?
If it says it came from God, then it
would have to be.
The New Testament also says it came from
God.
Okay. But you know the New Testament was
written in the go uh in the how would I
say the gospel writers narratives.
So what that doesn't mean so we believe
the gospire. We believe that the gospel
writers were inspired by God to write
what they wrote in the way that they
wrote.
Yeah. They're just so they're just the
tools that God used to to write down the
gospel.
That's that's still not my point,
though. I'm I'm trying to say that the
Injil is word by word infallible word.
I know. I know you you said that. I'm
asking you to substantiate that. Where
does your Quran say that the Injil is
the verbatim word of Allah?
Great point. That's that's like great
point. So, you want to compare the Quran
to the angel, right?
No, I said where did the Quran?
Yeah, but earlier we were talking about
You're missing it. You're missing it
again.
No, I get what you're saying.
I listen to the question I asked cuz you
said we believe that the Injil
is the exact word of Allah. Every word
of the Injil is God's exact word that he
nobody else's.
Yes.
So, my question is, can you show me
where the Quran gives that description
of the Injil? I can't give you a
verbatim word for word from the Quran,
but I can use critical thinking and can
then can I justify my editence?
Go ahead. Go ahead and give it out.
So, it doesn't give you an exact verse
saying that the Injil is in the
infallible word by word God. But what it
does say like you were giving a point is
is we know that the Injil was revealed
kind of in the same way that the Quran
was revealed. And if we know that if the
inje was revealed in the same way that
Quran was revealed, wouldn't it also be
using critical thinking the same how
would I say way God was speaking through
the Quran through the angel? See what
I'm trying to say?
I understand what you're saying. But
this So now let me show you how this
doesn't work.
Okay?
Because to have that assumption, you
need to substantiate that cuz I don't
even believe that the Quran is word for
word the words of Allah. Obviously, I
don't believe it's from God at all, but
you know, you have words of men in there
and all kinds of stuff. But, however,
this is what this is the case with the
with the gospel. I can also say the same
thing that the gospel are the are the
exact words of God in that the go God
gave the disciples what to write. He
inspired them what to write, pushed them
to on what to write. And literally, the
New Testament literally says this that
all scripture is God breathed. All of
it. The this what the New Testament says
about us. So New Testament.
So do you think it's the word by word of
God then?
So if you're saying if you're saying
that the angel is this particular
description that would cancel out the
New Testament, you have to show that.
Yeah. Yeah. So So let's let's get back
to the point that I was trying to say.
The gospel I believe is word by word.
You do not believe that with the New
Testament.
Can you show me that that's what the
gospel what the angel is? Cuz you can't
do that. I can't I can't show you off a
direct You're right. I can't show you
off a direct verse in the Quran, but I
can use critical thinking to show that.
So, can I use critical thinking in the
same way that to understand that the
inje what we know about the gospel from
for 2,000 years is that Jesus was going
around preaching this gospel orally and
that his disciples, his companions wrote
down what he did and taught and I that's
what the angel is. Can I also use
critical thinking in understanding that?
Yes. Yes, and no. Because they got to
pick what they wanted to put in there.
They were inspired on what to put in
there.
But they in the Okay. If I inspire you,
that doesn't mean I gave you the whole
entire stuff. That means I gave you a
part of it, but I didn't I didn't tell
you what to
I don't know what that means at all. If
I inspire you, if I inspire you to make
a million dollar business and then you
make a million dollar business off
selling catfish, that doesn't mean I
told you go make catfish and sell all of
this. You got the idea. You see what I'm
trying to say though? You got the start
of the concept.
Yeah. That's not what that's not what
divine inspiration is. We're not talking
about someone to start a business.
Divine inspiration is God is giving a
person revelation. inspiration to say or
do something
like give me an example.
That's not the same thing as I woke up
today and I was inspired by my friend to
start a business. That's not what that
is.
Okay. Can you just Can you give me an
example then?
I just gave it to you. Okay. Here's an
example.
Can I get an example? You gave me an
For example, I'll give you an example
from the Quran. The Quran says that
Allah inspired the disciples to believe
in Jesus.
Okay. So they got a revelation from God
that Jesus is true and a true messenger
of God.
It says that
Yeah.
Can you give me the verse?
Yeah. Chapter 5.
Yeah.
I think it's go to 111.
It said the disciples the disciples of
Jesus, disciple of Muhammad, excuse me.
The disciples of Jesus.
Okay.
You see how it says that they inspired
believe in Jesus.
Yes, he did. He said, "I revealed to the
disciples to believe in me and my
messengers."
Yep. And that they said, "We believe, oh
God, bear witness that they we are the
many ones."
Okay.
So Allah gave the disciples inspiration
and revelation of him and Jesus being
his prophet, the messenger.
Yes.
So that's a difference of of divine
inspiration and, you know, just some
regular human inspiration that they wake
up one day and I want to start a
business cuz I'm
No. Gotcha. Gotcha. No. No. Yeah. I see.
I see how that makes sense. But at the
same time, they're not all agreeing on
the same thing. Correct. When do they
disagree?
When do they disagree?
Yeah.
Well, they don't all like how would I
say there's they don't all say each
other's thing. That's that's the better
way to
say that again.
They don't all say each other's thing.
So like for an example, John claims that
Jesus said before Abraham, I am. And
then Matthew, Mark, Luke, none of them
made that same claim either.
So what?
So So what? Well, I think that's a very
very big point to have, especially since
John is one of the last disciples,
sorry, one of the last gospels to reveal
in
Yeah. What? But hold on. How does that
have any effect on the gospel?
How does that have any effect on the
gospel?
Yeah. If the if if if the other authors,
gospel authors did not record the same
statements that John recorded.
Yeah.
What does that what does that have to do
with anything? How does that affect
anything? I I think that would affect to
some extent because if I heard someone
say if I if I heard someone say before
Abraham I am and we only had one person
out of a group of disciples said he made
that claim. I I think that's very that's
why when it comes to I'm sure you know
about it where you need multiple for for
a you need multiple people to have heard
this and agreed upon
necessarily there's some
it depends who it came from like if it's
from his wife that's different. Ah, so
it depends on who it came from. So it's
coming directly from a disciple of John.
So why does it matter if the other
disciples didn't mark it down? It came
directly from his apostle, especially
the one he loved, actually.
Yeah, I agree. I agree. No, you're
right.
It doesn't matter.
I'm not I'm not going to sit here and
lie to you and make up It's
just it's just when it comes down to it,
and I don't want to be rude saying this.
I really don't. But when we talk about
the gospels themselves, it's like I
don't even know if I can how would I say
there's no eyewitnesses, you know,
that's one big point. We
according to what?
According to what? According to
textbased writing critics,
according to textbased writings, Matthew
wrote Matthew. Luke wrote Luke and Luke
got his got Luke got his testimony from
eyewitnesses. He literally says that.
Yeah. Yeah.
Mark Mark is Mark is dictating what
Peter himself wrote. So Peter's an
eyewitness.
Why why why does Bartman say that
and John and John
why does he say there's no eyewitnesses
then
why do why does why does Bart man's
teacher say that there are
his teacher says that
well
the one the one who he learned
how do you know how do you know if John
wrote John if correct me if I'm wrong
the oldest manuscript that we have of
John is what like 100 years after 70
no it's not yeah close to 70
okay so so do you understand these are
you the arguments don't work these
No, I'm going to I got you. Can I
finish?
No, but no, but if you're saying no,
hold on. You're saying you're saying
that the So, would your problem be Let
me just Let me just go with whatever
problem you're having. Are you saying
that your problem with trusting the New
Testament is that you don't know who
wrote the the New Testament? You don't
know exactly who wrote it?
It's not about exactly who wrote it.
Yes, it is.
Yeah. Yes. Yes. And no. Okay. If it came
from Okay. So, like you would agree that
Luke was Luke was illiterate, right?
No. Luke Luke was a physician. He was a
well educated man.
Okay. So he was educated. So you think
he actually sat there and wrote it in uh
Greek?
Yeah.
You think Okay. You do think he sat
there and read it in. He knew Greek.
That's something that you guys believe.
Yes. He was a Greek.
You believe all the disciples knew
Greek?
Yeah. It was a common language at the at
the time. Why not?
Do you think Jesus knew Greek?
Absolutely. He spoke with Greek soldiers
and centurions.
See, that's something I didn't know.
From what I've what I've researched, I
always thought Jesus didn't spoke Greek
and he
Do you know that the word in jail itself
is is a Greek word? It's not
I know. I know that it comes event is in
the
evangel. I knew it came from something
like that.
Yeah. So So even notice how your gospel
and everything that we must believe
about it literally matches the New
Testament. What's the problem?
I don't think it matches the New
Testament because it's and I don't want
to be rude when I say this. It's that
whole idea of divinely inspired. I don't
think
I showed you that even your Quran says
that the disciples were divinely
inspired.
Yeah, but it doesn't say the angel was
divinely inspired. It says
it says the angil came from God.
Yeah, but that doesn't Sorry. It doesn't
mean uh how would I say that it was
divinely inspired like the people who
wrote it were divinely inspired.
But it says Okay. Do you believe that
the disciples wrote the in?
Do I believe that the disciples wrote
the angel?
Yeah.
No, I I don't. I actually don't.
Okay. Boom. So now, so now, now you're
actually you're in more trouble than I
am because I actually have
Are you saying like the disciples?
Let me show you. When you're referring
to this, you're referring to Matthew.
The disciples of Jesus. The disciples of
Jesus. So this is the problem that you
have with my New Testament. I know who
wrote it. We have names. We have
tradition that accompany the names. No
other difference. In all of early
Christianity for 2,000 years, there's
never been a question on who wrote the
gospel. Matthew, Mark, Luke, John has
always been titled to write the gospel
all throughout church history. Never a
disagreement on that. And we have them
being divinely inspired. Even in both
the Quran and the Bible, the disciples
are divinely inspired. Now, here's the
problem. If you're saying that you can't
trust the New Testament because, and I
heard you say this, we don't know if
they were really eyewitnesses because
Bart Arman doubts that they were
eyewitnesses and so on and so forth. And
so, you're leaning towards that. Bart
Arman is your is your authority. You
keep mentioning him. So you are unaware
if they were eyewitnesses who wrote this
injil and we go over to the injil the
actual angel that you believe in. You
don't know who wrote it and you don't
know if the people who wrote it were
divinely inspired. The disciples in the
Quran were divinely inspired but you
don't know if they are the ones who
wrote the the NGO. So it could have been
written by some people who were not
eyewitnesses and not divinely. So why do
you trust why do you trust the NGO?
I trust the NGO because the NGO was
given directly to Jesus. Meaning he had
authority of what was going to be put
into it.
How did Wait, where where does it say
that Jesus decided what goes into the
inje?
Where do I say that? Well,
where does the Quran say?
Sorry. Sorry. I I misqued myself. I
misqued myself. What I meant to say is
that Jes Jesus's exact words like him
reciting it. That is what got put into
the not Matthew or Mark giving their
own. How do you know that?
How do I know that?
Yeah.
Because the same way you said that the
the Injil is like the Quran and the idea
that it was revealed to a prophet and
then it was written down by companions
or people. Okay. Is the same way I'm
saying the Injil was revealed
by who?
Who revealed the Injil?
No, no, no. Who who wrote it?
Who wrote it? Now, me personally, I
don't know.
So, why do you trust it?
Why do I let you Why? Let me show you
why this is important question. You
don't trust the New Testament. And a
reason why you said you don't trust the
New Testament is because you don't know
who wrote it. So you don't know who
wrote the Injeal. So why do you trust it
when you don't know who wrote it?
I know who wrote it.
Okay. Who wrote it?
No.
All God. It was It was God's It's God's
words. It's He's the one.
So So Allah himself wrote down the
No, he didn't.
Okay. Who wrote it?
Maybe. To be honest with you, I can't
give you their names. Like I'm not going
to lie.
So then do you see that? So I'm I'm just
using your logic. Yeah.
You don't trust the New Testament
because you don't know who wrote the New
Testament. You can't you don't know if
they were eyewitnesses. You don't you
don't trust the authorship of it. You
don't know. So with this So you don't
trust it for those reasons. So with the
Injeal, same thing.
You don't know who you don't know if
they were wrote it.
You don't know. You don't know who wrote
it. Yeah.
You don't know the who if they were
eyewitnesses. So why do you trust the
NGO?
You say that one more time. So, why do I
trill?
Why do you trust the inje when you don't
know who wrote it? You don't know if the
authors were eyewitnesses. The same
reason why you don't trust Why do you
trust the
I trust the angel? Because I know who
the author of the was. The author of the
angel is the author of the gospels of
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John.
No, the authors of the gospel is is God.
Huh?
The authors of the gospel is God.
What? Well, you said it's you. Yes. And
no. God had ways inspiring those
authors, but he didn't tell but he
didn't tell he didn't tell the authors,
"Hey, make sure you include this. Hey,
don't use that word, use this word."
How do you know
that? How do you know that? That's my
question.
But see, my goodness, you're you're not
you're missing what's going on here. I'm
using the same reasoning that you're
using on why you trust the NGO. I can
say the same thing. Even though Even
though, guys, guys, please pay
attention. For some reason, you're
missing it.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
You need to be consistent. Stop being
don't like don't be like the others.
Don't be hypocritical. Be consistent.
All right.
If you're not going to trust the New
Testament because you don't know who
wrote it.
I don't mean right. Authored. I meant
authored. I don't know who authored it.
That's what
Well, it claims to be authored by God.
Just like the Quran claims the angel is
authored by God. So, what's the problem?
What's the problem is? Yeah. The problem
is is how it was transmitted from
what's the problem?
How was it transmitted from God to Jesus
to the disciples? How how was that
transmitted or
Okay, tell me tell me what's the problem
with the transmission of the New
Testament that causes you not to trust
it, but instead trust the NGO. What's
the problem with the transmission?
Because because and I'm I don't want to
be rude saying this, the gospels, we
cannot confirm that Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John wrote those gospels.
And we're back to square one. So again,
instead of saying, "No, my problem is
the author is I know the author's God."
No, that wasn't it. You're back to
saying because I don't trust the authors
or the the people who wrote it, the
names of the people who wrote this
stuff, Matthew, Mark, Luke, John, or
Paul. I don't know who wrote it. I don't
trust
So you're the people who read the I
don't trust the people often. I got you
guys.
Guys, do you have names or eyewitnesses?
No, I I see what you're trying to say. I
do. I do. I I see what you're trying to
say. You're trying to say that the
because I don't know who authored the
Injil. Why should I not trust the New
Testament? Cuz I don't know who authored
the New Testament either. That's your
point you're trying to say. Here's what
I'm trying to say. Okay. I don't know
who authored the Injil. You're right.
I'm not going to deny that. Okay. What
I'm trying to say is that because I
don't know who authored the Injil and I
don't know who authored the New
Testament, it's irrelevant in the end
because that's why we have the Quran to
come in and come in and how would I say
show how it was to be the last message
to cement it?
No. Where does the Quran say it's the
last message to cement the Injeal? Where
does the Quran say that?
And then it say the the Quran is a
protector between the Injil and the
Torah.
It's a guardian of them.
Guardian. So, but it doesn't decide
what's right and wrong in them.
It doesn't decide what's It says. No, it
does. It doesn't say you're supposed to
be judged by the Quran, not not the
judge judge the people by the Quran, not
the books.
What do you mean judge the people?
You're you use the Quran to judge the
people and not follow their vain desires
is what the verse says.
Yeah.
It says, "So, judge between them."
The Quran is
It says, "So judge between them by what
Allah has revealed to you and follow not
their vain desires." Books don't have
vain desires. It's a people. Um,
granted, granted, you got to understand
that we believe that people put their
vain desires into the Bible and the Old
Testament.
Where does the Quran say that? Where
does the Quran say that people put their
vain desires?
Wait, what are you trying to say?
Where does the Quran say what you're
saying? That it that people put their
vain desires in the books. Where does
the Quran say?
It said uh that the Quran does say that
people will write in the name of write
their own things and then say this is
the word of God, you know.
Okay, got you. So, if I'm writing if I'm
writing my own thing and I say that it's
the word of God, does that mean that I
added to the Quran?
You could be adding to it. We don't know
what you were adding to what you were
adding to.
Wait, hold on a second. You have a
Quran. I get a sheet of paper and I
start writing on it and I call it the
word of God.
Yeah.
Is this blank sheet of paper that I'm
now writing on and and putting my
teachings in, is this the Quran?
No, but in context, I'm pretty sure it
was referring to the scriptures.
Well, no, it is. It's saying, "Woe to
those who write the book with their own
hands, claiming that it's from God."
Yeah.
So, I'm writing I'm writing a book with
my own hands, claiming that it's from
God. Does that mean that I'm changing
the actual Quran?
Changing it?
Depends. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, if you're
copying from it and then changing it in
your own words, then yes.
Well, does that mean the actual Quran
has been changed?
Oh, you're saying the Quran's been
changed. No, but it's not referring to
the Quran as well.
Oh, see guys, see now he understands it
now. Was the Quran? Oh, yeah. No, it
doesn't mean Quran's been changed.
Now he understands it.
No, I'm saying I'm saying it doesn't
it's but in context it's referring to
the the Torah in the
Kais you're you're you're smart. We've
been talking for a minute. I know that
you're intelligent. So grasp what I'm
what I'm what I'm saying.
Okay.
If I write on a on a fake on a notepad,
okay,
I write my own teachings. I write my own
interpretations on this notepad and I
make it a book. Did I then change the
Quran by making up my own fake book?
No.
Why not?
Because you weren't you weren't, how
would I say, writing on the same piece
of paper of it. You were
very good. So, I wasn't going into the
actual Quran and changing what's in the
Quran, but I was making up my phone my
own book and putting my own
interpretations into in a fake book.
So, would you say can I can I say one
thing? What if I'm pretty sure the way
the context in the Quran was referring
to it is that they would take the
scriptures and then they would write
more into it.
No, the Quran doesn't say that. The
Quran says that they were writing fake
books.
So, I have a quick question.
Wait, wait. Did Wait, before you ask
another question, do you get what I just
said?
Yeah. Yeah.
The Quran says, "Woe to those who write
the book with their own hands."
Yeah.
Claiming it's from God.
So, did are these people changing the
actual book or are they making fake
books? They're making fake books.
Beautiful.
But they can the Quran So the Quran
doesn't say that they're actually going
into the actual book and putting their
own desires in it. No, they're making
fake books and relying on these fake
books as if it's the word of God.
Well, using context and critical
thinking.
That's what the context and critical
Yeah. But wouldn't it the context and
critical thinking be referring to the
Bible in the New Testament?
It's referring it says it's referring to
Jews specifically, not the not even the
NGO. Oh, you're talking about
And it says And it says that some of
them are doing this, not even all of
them. But notice still,
yeah, it says to them.
The point is, guys, that the Torah is
not being changed. That's the point. You
get it?
So, you think the Torah wasn't changed?
Wait, wait. Do you get the point of what
the Quran says?
Say one more time. I I didn't hear that.
That the Torah is not being changed.
They write fake books. The actual Torah
is still there and preserved.
Wait, wait. You're saying the Quran's
claiming that the Torah is preserved? Is
that what you're saying?
Yeah. Yeah. For example, go to chapter
2. Look, look. The verse that you're
talking about is 279 about they write
with their own hands. Go to chapter 2
verse 89. Watch what verse 2 verse 89
says. Go to chapter 2 verse 89. I'm
going to show you how if you think that
the Quran says that they're changing the
actual Torah, I'm going to show you how
stupid this is and you're just showing
that the Quran is a contradiction and
Allah is a terrible communicator.
Come on, man. I've been I've been
respectful this whole time. Like I'm
being respectful, too. I'm just being
like, you don't got to be like I'm not
dissing your God and stuff, you know?
I didn't diss your God. I'm saying your
argument, your position would be dissing
your God. I'm not dissing your God. If
if your position is true,
and now there has come to them the
glorious book from Allah fulfilling the
prophecies which is already with them.
And that's not what it says.
You said you said 89.
Yeah. Are you reading parenthesis or
something?
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Don't read the parenthesis. Read
the words that are not in parenthesis.
And when there has come to them, the
glorious book from Allah fulfilling
which is already with them and previous
to them they had been praying for
victory over those who disbelieved. Then
yet and yet that long that's this is in
parenthesis long awaited prophet in the
Quran not parenthesis came to them which
they recognized parenthesis also to be
the truth not parenthesis
that's enough
they just believed in it
you got you got a terrible translation
but the point is you see how it says
what do you mean
you see how it says he sent the Quran
fulfilling what they already have what
they have with them
fulfilling which is already with them oh
Allah is still oh the book from
fulfilling that what is already with
them.
Yes. So the Torah is with them, right?
Doesn't say it was preserved.
So is the Quran fulfilling an
unpreserved book?
It could be.
So this is what you got. So this
because it's
fulfilling I don't think you're I think
you're taking So then Allah
Allah would be fulfilling an a corrupted
unpreserved book.
No, I think you're taking it too
literal. I think you're talking Bro,
you're just walking away. Can I can I
can I at least finish my point? I'm
walking away because bro, I think that
we have reached a point where the
reasoning between us is it's done. You
know, I it's you're not being
intellectually honest. Or maybe you
actually do hold to this and believe
this.
I do. I like I really do. Like I that's
why
Do you really believe that Allah is
fulfilling and confirming book?
No, I don't think I don't think he's
fulfilling the unpreserved book, but I
think he's more of fulfilling like the
entire religion like like this is
it doesn't say that. Well, it doesn't
say he's fulfilling a unpreserved or
preserved book. It doesn't say.
So, if he's fulfilling what is with
them, what was with them?
The Torah and the the Bible, basically.
Beautiful. So, he's fulfilling the Torah
in the Bible. Is the Torah So, is he is
the Torah in the Bible, is it corrupted
and changed at this point?
Is the Torah corrupted and changed at
this point under Islamic belief?
Correct. Right.
Okay. So if the Torah that's with them
and the gospel that's with them is
changed and corrupted, this verse says
that the Quran is fulfilling the
corrupted Torah and the corrupted gospel
that they have. You really believe that
Allah
Wait, let me confirming.
But I got you.
Corrupted scripture
and stoned and now that they have come
to them.
Does that make sense?
No, it doesn't. I'm I'm agreeing with
you. I'm not going to deny it.
Good. Okay. Good.
Okay. Fulfilling that a process.
Scared me for a second.
No, bro. No, I hope I've been I mean I I
think we've been having a pretty good
conversation so far.
A good conversation is is is cool, but
once once the reasoning stops, that's
when it's not cool anymore.
No, no, no. I I I agree. I agree. And
they said our hearts I'm I'm going to
start from 88 to 89 if you don't mind. I
just want to just kind of like re
read to 91. Read to 91. 91 says
when it said to them believe in the
Quran, which is Oh, this is 91 which
Allah has sent down. They said we
believe only in the Torah which is had
been sent down to us and they deny
everything other than that and which has
since been revealed through it. The
Quran is the lasting truth and corbate.
Okay. So doesn't you I think you were
talking about the Quran being the last.
I think that right here this verse
helps. So is the last truth coronate
with which is already with them and
their own scriptures say we did not seek
to kill the prophets of Allah in former
times if you were real believers in the
for in the former scriptures. we have
before the Quran, the scriptures before
the Quran. So the Quran is saying so
this is what this is the problem that
you have either the Quran is actually
making sense in that it's confirming and
fulfilling a true books that are there
and preserved uncorrupted and unchanged.
Therefore it's confirming them and
fulfilling them or if you go with your
view Allah is confirming and fulfilling
corrupted and changed. So, can I can I
can I say something?
Say something to to that, please.
Yeah. So, here's what I believe. I
believe that and obviously I don't have
evidence for this, but maybe this is
maybe something that makes a little bit
more sense. The Torah in the NGO had a
prophecy in it and that's why the Quran
is fulfilling it. Now, granted, we don't
have
the Quran says,
well, it is. It's saying it's fulfilling
a prophecy. So, if the prophecy
Well, actually, that's not what the
Quran says. It doesn't even say
fulfilling. Actually the word is
confirm.
It's saying
I mean mine says fulfill.
I know but if you go to the Arabic the
word is madakan which means to confirm.
But you understand saka in in context.
You can't take a word in Arabic and just
say this means sodaka.
Yeah. In in context it means to confirm.
In in this sentence it's meaning to
confirm and not to fulfill.
Yeah. No the word is not fulfill.
Fulfill is another another word.
No no but you you don't understand. Sad
can mean fulfill.
No it says confirm. But it can mean
confirm.
No, it can't.
I mean, not confirm, fulfill.
No,
you're saying not at all.
I don't know, man. Like, I've I've heard
I've heard that word be used and fulfill
before.
No, you haven't.
It's not It's not something where I'm
like,
"Brother, the word is confirmed, man."
So, please let's not let's not play the
Let's not play the games. Your Quran
says that it came confirming the
scripture that
I wish I had my camera on. I would just
show you on my screen.
I know that you're reading on my screen.
I have the book.
I know that you're reading an English
translation that says fulfill. I I
believe that you're reading what's
what's in front of you. I'm telling you
that your translator who put it as
fulfill is wrong because the Arabic word
is madakan which means to confirm not
fulfill. That's a different word.
No. Okay. I take your word for that. I
mean I'm not obviously 100% I'm not
fluent in Arabic.
So please let's get let's let's get to
the core.
See how your Quran is saying that the
scriptures that they have with them is
true. Yeah,
it confirms it.
It does.
So, how can Allah be corrupted change
book?
Wait, you're saying it confirms it?
That's what it says.
Wait, let me let me pull that back up.
Would you say three
289?
289. I remember I remember I have
something highlighted on here. Let me
see if I can find it.
No, brother. Please stay focused.
No, I know. I know. I I am staying
focused. I'm I'm I'm trying to explain
this part to you. You said 289.
Yeah, there's nothing to explain it.
It's it's it's self-evident. So will
Allah be confirming corrupted scripture
which is already with them came for. So
you're saying it says to confirm cuz I'm
like I'm not trying to be rude or
anything but like it does it does say
fulfilling to me.
I don't care.
And now they come to the glorious book.
So even if it let's say if it confirmed
hypothetically. Okay
that's what it says in the
hypothetically.
Okay let's say it says confirm. Well
what is it confirming
their scripture?
Their scripture what being does that
mean it's being preserved? That means
it's true.
It's confirming their Yeah, it's
confirming that their scripture Oh,
you're saying their scripture is 100%
true.
That's what it says.
Well, it says it's confirming
what is with them.
Which is already with them. Confirming
that is which is already with them.
And you and we already said that what
they have is the Bible
and previous of those who had been
displaced, you know. No, I mean I'm not
going to deny it. Like I think you're
right on like I'm not going to deny
that. I still don't obviously the main
question was the angil and I still don't
believe that the the writers of the of
the New Testament gospels are the same
writers of the
who are the who are the writers of the
I don't know man
then how do you know that they're not
the same
that's doesn't matter I don't know who
those are
because
how can I say that no stop is because
you're using this as a reason to reject
the the gospels that we have today
you're saying I don't believe that the
authors of the gospel that you have are
the same authors of the NGL. Therefore,
I don't trust your gospel. So why do you
trust the NGL when you don't know who
wrote it? You don't know if it was the
same writers or not. So do you see
really inconsistency?
I don't I don't know who authored the
How do you know? How do you know that
the ones who wrote who wrote the gospel
that we have didn't write the angel? How
do you know?
I don't.
So then you can't reject the the gospel
that we have. You get the point? Or else
if you want to stay consistent, you can
reject the gospel of that we have also
reject the NGO. If you want to be
consistent,
right? Yeah. I mean, that would probably
be the thing like from an Islamic
perspective because we don't even have
the NGO. So, it wouldn't matter in the
end, right?
It does matter.
Well, if we you can't say that you don't
have the your scholars believe that you
have the NG that we have
scholars believe we have 100% of the
your scholars I I have a Quran right
here in my in the Quran right here. the
commentator. You know what those guys
that put in parenthesis?
Yeah.
When you go to like, for example, matter
of fact, let's let's see if it's in
yours, too. I don't know.
It's probably not, but keep going.
It's probably not. Go to chapter 7 in
your Quran for me.
Chapter what?
Seven.
Yeah.
All right. What verse?
here. Those who follow this perfect
messenger, the the Arabian prophet whom
they found described in the Torah and
the angel, which are with them. Who I
see which are with them. Now, what is
the Does it say anything in parenthesis?
No.
Okay. In mine, I don't know if you can
see.
I I can't really see that. Good.
All right. I'll just
You just read it. I don't need to make
it more difficult for you.
You trust me?
Yeah.
Right. In mine, in the parenthesis, when
it says Torah and Gospel.
Yeah.
It says Deuteronomy for the Torah. In
parenthesis, it says Deuteronomy 18:15.
Oh,
it's quoting him. It's saying like this
is Muhammad.
Yes.
Oh, okay. Okay. And then it says and the
angil in parenthesis gospel John 14 16
I'm sorry John chapter 10. Yeah.
Who's who's your commentator?
This is uh halali halal and halal halali
and khan. These are two doctors two
Muslim uh two
is it recent like how do you know when
that was published?
I don't I don't know. Let me see. I
don't know. Probably gives the year and
at the end or something but yeah. So
yeah this is Dr. Halali Halali and Khan.
Dr. Muhammad Taki Halali, PhD in Berlin
and Dr. Muhammad the year the year.
So even scholars scholars are quoting my
Bible as the angel that the Quran is
mentioning. Isn't that crazy?
Yeah. But you got to understand not all
scholars agree with each other.
I know. But but my point is is that it's
not an Islamic consensus that we don't
have the the today. That's silly.
There's even Islamic scholars and
commentators that believe we have the
Injeal.
Interesting. So do but then they still
believe they don't believe it's
corrupted then.
I don't know. I don't know their I don't
know his view on it. He might which
would be silly.
It'll be silly. It'll be silly for we
have the NGO but parts of it are
corrupted and parts of it is true. That
would be so silly to say.
Well you you I mean I have like a
genuine qu. You don't believe the the
Bible that you have not the Bible the
New Testament like the Gospels are 100%.
You believe that 100% the same words
that were revealed, the same meaning
that was revealed?
I believe it's what Jesus said.
So you do so you do think he claimed to
be God.
Absolutely.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean obviously that's not
something that Muslims believe and
but it's it's in the jail.
Yes and no.
No. There's no yet. It's not a yes or
no.
We I still don't. I still I still
understand the dilemma, guys. Understand
the dilemma.
The New Testament. either. So you have
these because
there it's with the Jews and the
Christians. It's it's true. It confirms
it. All of that. But you as a Muslim
want to tell me want to tell correct
Allah. Allah actually actually the angil
doesn't exist. It's gone. Matter of fact
Allah the injil has actually been
changed. So why are you saying Allah
that you're confirming the injil? Why
are you saying that Allah? We don't know
its authors. Allah, we don't know who
wrote the injil. Why would you confirm
it? Why would you send the Quran, Allah,
confirming the injil when we don't know
who who wrote it? We don't know the
authors, Allah. You see how silly that
is?
Interesting. No, I I agree. I won't lie.
I How would I say then if let's say the
Injil was the New Testament. Okay, not
the New Testament, the Gospels. Okay,
not the New Testament, just the Gospels.
If the New Testament was just the
Gospels, okay, what evidence can you
give me that truly shows that John wrote
John, Matthew wrote Matthew, Luke wrote
Luke, or is it more of a faith
conviction based?
It's tradition and internal information.
Okay.
Okay. So, all of our church fathers
agree that John wrote John. There's
never been a difference. manuscripts
with confirming the until confirming the
names. All all all all the manuscripts
that have the title all title it John.
Now
I'm saying I'm saying what's the
earliest do we have of that?
I I I don't know. I couldn't tell you.
Is it is it the Codeexcus? Would you say
that?
No, there's there's earlier manuscripts
of John that we that we have that's
before the Codexus is just a completed
New Testament. That's the first
completed of
New I know.
So as as far as the earliest manuscript
of John, I couldn't I couldn't exactly
tell. So from what I've No, it's not
even the earliest manuscript of John.
I'm saying the earliest manuscript of
claiming to be John. Like
but I I can give you like I can give you
what some Islamic sources say that John
wrote John.
Islamic sources saying John wrote John
like a hadith.
Yeah. Frombach. You know who that is?
I do know who I is. So in the earliest
life story of the life of the prophet
Muhammad the surah records a story from
Muhammad talking about sending out his
companions to spread the message of
Islam similar to how Jesus sent out the
disciples to spread the gospel and he
says literally he says the gospel that
John wrote down for him
and do you know the number
what page number is that guys in Iben
the life of the prophet what page is
that what page is that guys I forgot
104. Thank you. Thank you. Study
104 shock.
Yep.
I don't have it with me, but I mean I
just typed it down. Just I'm going to
look that up later.
You want me to show you? I could open my
computer.
Well, we can we can get back to that. I
don't want to be rude because you know
you have what is the up there.
Well, we're talking about the NG.
I Well, even Ash's talking about John,
but we can go back.
He says that John wrote the
He's saying that John wrote the Is he
saying he's the only author of the
He just He just mentions John. He
doesn't say
he is that the only person who says John
wrote John.
That's that's what I have. I don't know
about anybody else.
Okay. So, he doesn't confirm Matthew or
Mark or Luke writing either of them.
He confirms that they were disciples of
Jesus.
I agree they're disciples of Jesus. I'm
not denying. Every Muslim in the world
believes that Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John are disciples of Jesus.
That's a lie. No, they don't.
No, let me finish. Can I finish?
But we don't believe But we don't
believe that. I just don't believe that
Matthew, Mark, Luke, or John wrote their
actual gospels.
Okay. Yeah. But No. Yeah. No. So,
Muslims do not do not believe that the
names that are attributed to the
disciples, they don't believe them as
disciples.
So, you Well, obviously, I don't think
Mark was named Mark. He was probably
named whatever his Greek or
No, they don't believe they don't The
disciples that are attributed in the
Bible, they don't believe in them.
None of them.
So, they don't Well, but they do believe
he had disciples.
Yep. They just don't know who they were.
Okay. They just don't know who they
were.
If you go to early Islam, though, early
Islamic scholars affirm the disciples
that we have in the Bible. And this is
which is why you have Muhammad who says
that John wrote John wrote the gospel of
Jesus. John wrote the inje
I'm very interested on on the the whole
idea of the because obviously from what
I've read personally it doesn't make it
doesn't I've always heard that the
wasn't the New Testament you know and
what I've even read in the Quran like
like a lot of people like judge by the
or let the people of the judge by the
angel and um something that I always
thought is like oh you know that's just
referring to the original
doesn't say that
what do you mean
do you see how you have to add to the
Quran in order to get over the fact that
the Quran is referring to what we have.
What did I add to the Quran?
Oh, it's referring to the original
injury.
I said that's what I thought. I didn't
say the Quran said that. I said that's
what I always thought.
I know. I know you're So, you're you're
in your thoughts. You're adding to the
Quran.
Yes, you're right. I am adding. You're
right. It's not I didn't even think it
was adding. I thought it was more of the
context the context of it.
Well, yeah, that's that's not it.
Because if even if you're talking about
the original, that wouldn't be what was
originally the original because that's a
six that would be a 600y old document
that they have right there with them
that they're judging by, you know. So,
no
that they would they would be holding on
to
So, you don't think at all? Just I'm
just I'm just curious. You don't think
the angel was given to Jesus and then
how would I say
no?
So, so this is this is where I'm
confused. The gospel. This is this comes
from an ignorance of what the gospel is.
Jesus himself was the gospel. He himself
was the good news.
No, I know. But the but that's not what
the angel is.
That's exactly what the angel is.
That you think the angel was Jesus
himself?
The angel the gospel. Yes. Even the even
the Quran says that you you know so
they said the Quran says we gave Jesus
the angel. So how did he give himself?
The Quran is wrong about what the gospel
is.
No, but I'm explaining it from an
Islamic point of view. There is no
explanation of it because you don't know
what it is. That's why that's the point
of this question. If you come from an
Islamic perspective, you don't have an
answer on what the angel is. You don't
know who wrote it. You don't know when
it was written. You don't know nothing
about it. You don't even know what was
in it. You don't know.
Yeah, you're right. I don't know what it
is.
So,
but it in the end, if you got to look at
from
when in doubt, this is what the Quran
says. When in doubt, come to us. Go to
the people of the book. That's what you
should do when you want to know what the
angel is. Come to the people who have
it. Don't say we don't have it when you
don't know what it is. That's silly.
Interesting. No, I I definitely I
definitely didn't. How would I say? I
didn't think that the Jew was referring
to the New Testament. There's there
hadith Can I ask you are there hadith of
the prophet? I'm sure there are where he
denies it.
Never.
Never a hadith where he denies it.
I'm gonna have to do my own research on
that. I'm I'm sure I'm sure that there's
got to be What? Okay. Hypothetically, if
I were to find obviously it probably
wouldn't change anything to you, but I'm
I'm sure there's some sort of hadith
that refers to the scriptures of the
the, you know, the Jews and the the
Christians to be corrupt.
Nope.
I'll look into that a little bit more.
Muhammad never never says that our
scriptures are corrupt. Now, what you'll
this is what you'll find. I'll tell you
what you'll find. If you go to Hadith,
the closest thing that you're going to
find is Ibn Abbas quoting chapter 2
verse 79 where we talked about those who
write the book with their own hands.
Yeah.
So you have Iban Abbas in in Sahib
Bukari. Iban Abbas would say you know
basically don't take anything from the
Jews and the Christians or why would you
take anything from the Jews and the
Christians when you know that they have
distorted their scriptures distorted and
changed their scriptures and wrote books
with their own hands right when you have
the Quran. So I know in like one hadith
in Bkari 4987, I'm sure you know that
where it's like standardizing the Quran
and everything. In that same hadith,
Uman talks about how he was scared that
the Quran was going to be changed just
like the the Christians and the Jews.
Well, no, he doesn't say that. He says
he was worried.
So somebody comes to Uman worrying
saying, "Save us from these
differences."
Yeah. Yeah. before we defer about the
book like the Jews and the Christians
defer about their book.
Yes.
So, not that the actual book has
changed, but that people are having
differences.
I think they both agree though that
things were added into the Bible and
that they're still stayed in here today.
Nope.
I don't agree that things were added to
the Bible.
Yeah. So, remember how I kind of brought
up but again,
you don't believe about the story of
adulterous.
Do you remember what the response was to
that? Yeah, we have texts from earlier
sources. So So why do you
So that would mean that the Bible's
still preserved, right?
So why why do you
Wait, wait, wait. That would mean that
the Bible's still preserved, right?
Depending on what your manuscripts are.
If you losing my patience.
No, I'm I'm not even trying to be mean
like that, bro. Like
it's not about being mean. It's about
It's about not being
Well, I'm sorry. I'm not I'm not a
scholar of Christianity.
You don't have to be a scholar. You have
have common sense.
All right. Well, I'm explaining to you.
How can someone know if something's
added
from looking at text before? So that
that means that they have preserved text
before to know if something's added. Is
that correct?
Yes. So why
So that means that what they have is
preserved.
Why do they leave it in then?
So that's why they so that means they
have what what they have is preserved,
right?
Like do you still tell that story? I
have a question.
So that's what that means that what they
have is preserved. Correct.
Yes.
Okay, good. That's it. That's it. Now I
don't So what I'm saying is I don't
believe that that's a fabrication. But
if I grant it to you that it is, if I
grant it to you that this is something
that was added, that just proves that we
still have the preserved text to know
that it was added.
No. No, I see what you're saying. But
you don't think it was You don't think
it was added?
No, I don't.
Can you elaborate why?
I just don't.
You just don't think it was added. Okay.
Now, we we can go into that on on
another day
in jail right now, cuz that's that's not
that's besides the point.
No. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I like I said
when the Quran reveals to reveals the to
Jesus.
So you so what what we have is is that
you have no reason to reject the New
Testament or else you're going to reject
the inje. That's where we're at. So
which one do you want to do? Do you
accept the New Testament finally or are
you going to be consistent when you
reject the New Testament and also reject
the NG?
What if I just What do most scholars do?
They just reject both of them.
If you want to be an atheist,
is that what they No, come on. They they
reject both of them. Well, what I don't
know. I got to see what the scholars
point of view is on that.
All right. Well, take care.
No. Yeah. Yeah. I had a really good
conversation, man. I hope we, you know,
we can talk again. Thank you so much for
letting me on, man. For real. Hope it
was a good conversation, man. They